après le départ des réfugiés rwandais
installés maintenant dans des camps goma
au zaïre retrouvent un semblant de calme
la vie reprend le petit commerce aussi
envoyés spéciaux philippe gassot et
franck brice et le flot des réfugiés
rwandais remonter à présent sur les
camps aura laissé la ville de goma
exergue elle n'en avait pourtant pas
besoin
les prix sont montés la vie est dure
pour la plupart des zaïrois et là encore
les enfants sont les plus démunis
l'école est finie
que faire l'eau courante n'est pas pour
demain ce sont les coatis qui remplace
les robinets ils assurent
l'approvisionnement
les loisirs sont rares et la circulation
aussi excepté les véhicules de l'aide
internationale
on s'amuse donc comme on peut même si
c'est dangereux et gratuit
ça fait quand même envie quand les
grands essaie de se débrouiller en
créant par exemple la moto taxi les plus
petits ne sont pas en reste
le tout c'est d'avoir au départ le
capital vélo pas d'étude de marché la
clientèle existe les bénéfices rentrer
ce matin avec tomber l'autre à gagner ça
oui
y avait lancé me disais comment ça
disait oui et tu le loup ici sur la
route
oui mille zaïre ces trois ou quatre
kilos de haricots
c'est beaucoup d'argent c'est 200
ailleurs le tour il ya aussi le foot
avec un très gros problème de ballons
l'évidence et puis de l'autre côté du
mur
ce qu'on ne regarde même plus les
orphelins du matin chagrin se sont
réfugiés on les a trouvées au bord des
routes
deux souffrent du choléra on n'a pas
prévu de nourriture ils vont attendre
comme ça vous savez y en a tellement
ce matin il y a encore eu de mort une
journée ordinaire dans une petite rue de
goma dahir